welcome back to on base live I am your
host Mookie Betts and today we have
Francisco Lindor how you doing bro I'm
doing great living the life I always
wanted all right bro so so you got four
All-Stars two gold gloves two silver
Sluggers and one big beautiful smile bro
so you said uh you would be a dentist if
you weren't playing baseball what time
yeah how did that come about like my
teeth were I always had a good shape of
teeth my tooth were they had a good
shape however they were beat up man it
was like neighbors and never been before
they were they were they were there but
they weren't living together they were
in different rooms so what did you do
what did you get breakfast I got braces
yeah I got braces and and um my dad
couldn't really afford him when I was
growing up neither my mom and my dad
always said no you're fine you're good
you're good they tried I signed
professionally I said man I gotta get
this that's the first thing oh well
we'll talk about with the first thing so
so I like to uh play this game called on
base off base you know your inner out
first thing is
Lewis Hamilton will win another
championship I mean you're in on that I
mean you're on base on that so Lewis
Hamilton that's your one of your
favorite drivers yeah yeah yeah and
are you a huge F1 fan or just a big
driving fan what are we talking here I
am I'm I'm a friend of the sport but I'm
also Lewis Hamilton fan as well
um I I respect his um background and and
what he has done for the for the F1
um sport you know he he transcended it
he crossed the bridges which is one of
the things I'm sure you want to do some
things I want to do as well you know
cross Bridges and and um not just impact
baseball people yourself everybody
everybody are you gonna go in November
I mean I
we always got something we always do
have something we always got something
you're right so if you got a chance
if he has a chance Lindor will be there
I think I'm gonna go too yeah to a race
and nothing like I went to the one in
Austin uh how was it it was sick that's
when I actually fell in love with the
sport it was 2019 I believe and I went
with new balance and
like use one of those shows where it's
almost like the U.S open here where it's
one of those events that you get into it
and you're like wow this is like very
very clean very cool very like just
organized and I like going to places
that I
I can be on the radar okay yeah yeah oh
yeah I know yes so so do you just you
just watch them go around and
yeah I'm just trying to figure out he's
made it sound like I mean I don't I'm
not disrespected yeah they go they go
around they disappear for a couple
seconds and now it's on the phone you
hear the car driving by again okay all
right so on base off base what about
pineapple on pizza and I have my opinion
about this um I'm off why are you off
because fruits you keep it separate and
because I'm a pepperoni guy oh you're a
pepperoni guy pepperoni yeah I'm with
you I I I'm off on pepperoni I mean uh
the pineapple being on Pizza
um yeah I just have Italian friends and
Italians say pineapples do not go on
Pizza yeah other than that so you've
been educated on it yes yes yeah but
other than that I don't have another
reason for it yeah but it makes perfect
sense
fruit over here yeah it's over here yeah
I'm saying yeah so what about okay
buying your teammate a car for personal
accolades
um I'm on for it I'm on face so you said
you would get you know a car for the
batting title yeah I I will I will get a
car it's just no matter what car I'm
getting yeah that's that's the that's
the the question what car am I gonna get
my teammate for winning Valentine yeah
so when when are you I think the the
fans out there yeah and myself we're all
making we're trying to figure out when
is he gonna do this when are you
thinking about doing this I don't know
just whatever it's my wallet okay so
so yeah yeah it's gonna happen at some
point though yeah I'm not sure when yeah
but you're gonna maybe a Hot Wheel it
might be a golf cart okay you might be
able to say you didn't specify I didn't
it was a walking by thing the person was
in the other side of the room I said man
if you want to buy and talk I'll get you
a car okay and boom your wallet and so
you determine what kind of car what kind
of car and when he gets to go and when
he gets I love that he will get the car
he will get the promise you that all
right what about uh are you in or out on
base off base on uh naps during
really naps in general naps at the field
I mean you're in sorry so do you go to
the field early just to take a nap
I always go to a few early
um I try to get to it for 1 32 o'clock
um but before BP I mean before game I
always I always try to take a nap how
long always 20 25 minutes that's the
perfect I feel like that's the perfect
time yeah you start going more than that
and you are flat out
no you know I just want to get
re-energized yeah I function very well
very well extremely well in
when I fall asleep in the car and also I
get up oh then you're ready you're ready
to go okay okay so so what about I it
was said that you took a nap during a
rain delay in the world in the world
series I went so this is what happened I
I walked in the clubhouse and the whole
entire Club was wrapped up
oh okay all right okay that's number one
yeah it was wrapped up I didn't want to
see that right I didn't want to see it
yeah people scattered they're going they
went in different directions some people
stay in the clubhouse some people went
to the kitchen some people went to the
and I went to the weight room okay and I
was so like nervous and the whole entire
month you know how it is that that first
time in the playoff that whole month
especially making another way
I had stomachache after stomach ache you
know
like it's the butterflies are just
constantly there and I went to the
weight room and I in the this those um
mattress that we have in the weight room
I just laid there and
I was there for like
10-15 minutes
um
yeah and and then I I got up and it was
like all right but how did you fall
asleep though because you the you're
it's in the World Series right now and
yeah like what
yeah well I mean how did you get sleepy
no it's not about it's not about being
sleepy it's about putting your mind
putting your your body and your mind in
a different state where you can those
out when you go to uh I don't know if
you've ever been to a meditation class
yeah I'll never have
go to it and I I don't you could be
sleep for 10 hours you go to a
meditation class you start taking
yourself to different breaths you start
taking yourself to different
um moments you dozed out those off like
you
you you are there but you're not there
so you didn't did you even realize you
fell asleep I no it was one of those
where I was trying to like come myself
just lay down and down sudden
all right let's go let's go back to this
so you were you and it asked me it
wasn't like I was trying to post no
right yeah I was trying to meditate you
you're trying to calm down because you
knew especially when you saw the when
the clubhouse being wrapped up you know
what that means yeah yeah so you're
you're now it's like okay you know we're
about to win you know X Y and Z whatever
let me just go calm down because we do
have to finish the game and I'm I'm
pretty sure I'm
I'm sure their Clubhouse probably was
wrapped up I'm not I don't I don't know
this for 100 but I'm
I think we were in Extra Innings like
yeah yeah either one right it's game
seven yeah so I'm sure both sides of the
club is where we don't want this to get
beat up you know what I'm saying
um so I I'm not sure I never asked them
but I'm pretty sure their Clubhouse so
it's they probably had champagne on
their side we had champagne on our side
it was just a matter of printing the
logo and saying yeah
Indians okay so what about Donovan
Mitchell
will play for the Knicks are you on base
or off base on that I'm on I'm on the
base are you you're you're just a sports
fan in general yeah I mean you're
Donovan Mitchell are you down he's a
Mets fan yeah Mitchell so you're you're
I'm a fan I'm a fan of people oh okay of
players players yeah I I follow Sports
because of players not so when you go
watch an NBA game or a Knicks or I'm
sorry or a uh NFL game
you're gonna you're not necessarily
going to watch the team
not really you're going to watch
whoever's playing yeah I'm like that
yeah and and number one
I I get the sport but I'm not fully
educated I never played them right I
never played those Sports so I don't I
don't know all the little move and
strategies that happened in the game you
know and oh I would do this play I go
because I know someone and or I
know the players player is really good
and I I love seeing athletes
at the highest level yeah play be at
their Peak I love seeing the best
athletes play the best yeah yeah that
just makes me better yeah and it's very
cool it's inspirational to watch 100
yeah so okay so what about talking to uh
talking to your infielders or
third baseman second baseman during the
game do you talk to them during are you
on base or off base on that yeah so and
this is not just hey we're about to turn
two right here hey two out this is just
having a regular conversation regular
conversation you do this regular
conversation so what what like what
would be a conversation that you and I
call them Mac but uh Jeff what do you
what would be a conversation I mostly
talk to my right side so baby yeah baby
with the Indians who was Ramirez yeah
um Escobar oh sorry Guardians I was with
the Indians okay I'd never played for
the Guardians yeah you know with the
Indians yeah with the Indians I couldn't
say with the gardens yeah
I just didn't want to offend anybody no
no no no no no no now is the gardens
yeah yeah we got that but when I was
there
um
it I'll give you one yesterday
um with baby we were two
I like to be in the moment I like to
looking at I like following the baseball
okay and then putting my sights on the
catchers that gets me back into the
moment back in the game and I will tell
baby baby
he's swinging and baby's like nah not
this you know and we go back in
okay and then it's like all right you're
you're up
no he's not swinging like yeah he's
swinging okay you know we get back in
okay I think just stuff like that and I
I know being a shortstop
when the game was slower I was able to
spot spot everybody and defense
everybody everybody that I wanted
friends family wife that came to the
game I knew exactly when they got up and
when they did it do you still the even
though it's going quicker do you still
because if my wife's at the game My
friends are at the game I always look
for them wave to him yeah let them know
like I see y'all I know y'all see me all
right now I can go focus on the game
like is that is that kind of a thing for
you it is it truly is it's it's one of
them where
I'm here you're here for me I'm here for
you yeah I'm putting on a show for you
yeah and so I yeah that's exactly what
it is okay so let's switch gears
going into this season right but not
even going into the season this season
in general for the Mets yeah
y'all you guys owner
came out and and he had kind of talked
and said like you know at some point
it's on the players right the players
got to play better and
first of all how do you feel about that
how was the the clubhouse what kind of
when that went on like when he said that
yeah no that press conference he kept it
so when he said it was at a press
conference the other press conference
and
um
he kept it very professional he kept it
real he
um and when you educating the subject
most of the time
you're gonna be in tune with what's
happening right you know and I respected
it I thought it was a great press
conference
um and he's right right gotta play
better yeah you know we got to play
better I said it yesterday too
um front officers can put the best team
together in in on paper yep but if us
the players don't execute and don't come
out and and do the job
it's not the best team that's exactly
what it is I mean that's exactly like
we're the ones that affect the game the
most obviously yeah they do make you
know pitching changes and whatnot that
affects the game right but even the guy
has to come in and execute his pitches
correct it doesn't matter what the
match-up is and so you know I I
definitely respect him for saying that
but what what about the The Vibes in the
clubhouse like when he said that was it
like okay did you like
you're the leader obviously yeah you're
signed here for a long time you know I'm
saying everybody respects you everybody
loves you you know I'm sure you got some
other leaders right but I would say when
you think of the Mets you think of
Frankie Lindor and so did you have to
kind of have a meeting or was it
something that's kind of understood you
didn't have to talk about like what was
it what was the vibe oops
coming into the field it was definitely
a very different
field it was it was one of those were
you are you're walking in and you see
um people almost like trying to figure
out understand what's happening I'm like
guys nobody's getting fired today right
like he's he's educated he understands
he gets it he respects he if somebody
was gonna get fired today it wouldn't
have happened already it's not going to
be in the press conference
he's fired you know right it might have
been news for everybody else but not for
the players right not for the coaching
staff
um once the press conference was done it
was like all right he gets it he he is
exactly where we're at
he's right we got to be better and then
you guys played you know I think it was
like a week or so right before the break
he played well right before the break
and so now coming out of the break what
what is something that did you guys have
a talk like okay this is what we're
gonna do going forward
um you know and obviously this is we're
in the big leagues right we're all
professionals we're all 30 years old or
20 you know 20 years old for some of the
young guys but
um so what is it that you guys are are
trying to do in a small like the small
details like are we going to you know
pitch better but obviously gonna do
everything better but what small details
that are you guys going to focus on to
get you over those hump over this hump
yeah I think it's just a matter of
the attitude and just being there for
each other okay yep it's it's it's not
one of those just like man
I gotta be a better defense defensive
shortstop because whether we're playing
well or not I gotta be better right you
got to be good oh I got to be a better
hitter playing well or not you got to be
the mentality for us is not like
um
just because things are going bad I
gotta play better right you know
things are going good I've got to play
better you know no matter what no no
matter what no matter what it's you
hitting 240 or hitting 320 you still
want to be better you still want to get
and that's the game that's this game
right and that's that's that's we
that's the grind that we love that's our
competitive Chase yes it's that shades
of
being the best yeah just being the best
it is so hard you know it's so hard it
is and we just got to focus on on
playing the
the game putting games together yep you
just got to put the games together all
all aspects of the game put it put them
together put it together you know it's
hard it is it is very hard so but and we
both have played for big cities you came
from the Indians yeah now and then came
to New York what is it like being in a
big city when you're going from
Cleveland to to New York what was it
like what was that transition like not
not the
baseball trains or I'm sorry not the
moving not just the the pure City
transition like how how is that for you
um what was it like
it was good it was good but he was tough
it was it was tough to in Cleveland
I
it's almost like
I saw the same people okay you know and
here you see the same people as like the
workers like the the security guards
they're the same and you you build a
relationship with them whoever is
opening the door in the clubhouse you
know you build that relationship with
them and the same thing in Cleveland and
I love the orientation it was amazing
and the fan base was was great coming in
here I
I always heard big Market big markets
and I just thought the big Market was
the the media okay yeah no I just
thought it was just gonna be okay
there's gonna be more media because
that's what
every time I went to a bigger market
like to play
against them there was more media it's
always more media yeah right it was like
it was the same I'm on the fans 35 000
40 000 30 000 whatever saying I'm on the
fence but there's now I understand it's
more the fan base is that it's bigger
you know and you you see more Mets hats
you see
um
people coming in and out I always take
the time to try to sign
um other graph before a game like five
minutes yep um before a game and in
Cleveland I could see like a very I got
you I got you three weeks ago I don't I
know I seen you but we're like no man I
got you I got you twice yesterday yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I have those but it's it's hard it's
hard yes and it's there's always new
people yeah you know and to me that's
cool it's cool to to interact with
um other people as well what about what
about
it being tougher I mean I'm assuming you
know playing in Cleveland playing
anywhere really is is not Nothing's
Gonna Be Easy right but now you're in
New York yeah like if you don't play
well in New York they let you know quick
and so how was that like how do you use
that what you know what is it about that
that you'd like or that was one of the
things that was one of the things I
couldn't understand in the beginning I
got booed
um
essentially two months
two months every day okay you know and I
could I made my the fair amount of my
mistakes yeah I wasn't hitting so you
know they they're doing it I wasn't
performing they're they're they're
letting me have it
um and I didn't get it I didn't
understand it uh I I
I'm like the thought that I always had
was man I'm giving everything I got I'm
trying to put up a great show for for my
family for the fans for organization and
for myself it's just not
it's
I just it's not translating and I was
making the mistakes and
and then I finally understood I talked
to a lot of Veteran people better than
players and I talked to a lot of people
that played the game here and they said
and I also had conversation with people
that were just fans okay
um and they said we just want the
results
you could be anybody and if the result
the results are not there
you're gonna hear and that changed
changed my mindset it was like oh I I
got it I got it so I could get a base
hit the cheer and I could strike out or
roll over into a dole play and they're
gonna boo me or they're just gonna be
mad yeah okay I got it it's the results
it's the it's yeah I'm the one that's
putting the the results however but
it's most likely the result and then
when they see me in the street they're
gonna say hello yeah that's exactly it
yeah yeah I kind of yep I said man I
I'll play hard I'll do whatever I got to
do every day I I just got to be better
yeah I've been saying that ever since I
got here I just got to be better I just
gotta be I'll probably say the rest of
my career so how do you balance let me
ask you this how do you balance because
this game is yes it is result oriented
it is
it is but it's also process oriented
yeah so how do you how do you balance
the two because we have to stick to a
process in order to get to the result
and it's not that process doesn't always
yield a result like we could do this
process over and over and over again and
get different results that are all
negative so how do you balance
no I'm not gonna say worrying is the
wrong word but no
getting the result that you want and
need for yourself and for the fans but
also sticking to a process you balance
with your teammates you just feed up
them and you of the with the coaching
staff you you stay you gotta your
foundation got it very strong okay and
you have to
understand that the process is the most
important the results are going to be
there
based on the process and how you do go
about your business
um
and just don't cut don't get caught up
in that wave you know you just gotta
when they say try to be as level as you
can it is a real thing and that's hard
to do yeah like I I feel like because I
played in big markets and for me it's
I use the results to kind of direct me
in my process so if I'm rolling over a
lot then I change my process in order to
fix the rollover in order to get a no
result but I gotta stick to
the process because if I don't do a
process yeah and I just focus on results
horrible I'm gonna be I'm gonna be I'm
I'm gonna be terrible yeah and you're
not you don't you don't know what to fix
you know you don't know really what it
is because you know it's just a mindset
and it's hard to uh it's hard to switch
your mindset in that mindset that that's
that's very important because you can
focus on the process you can focus on
mechanics you can focus on whatever you
got to do in order to not roll over but
if I go to the box working on what
exactly what I was working in the cage
yeah you spend all day fixing it and
then you do the same stuff yeah so let
me ask this bro
you got two kids yeah man how is that
it's fantastic when I say I'm doing
living the life I always wanted that's
it I always envision myself like this so
how how do you say the first I don't
want to how do you say the first name
Amapola I'm Apollo and what does that
means that flower it's the Hibiscus
flower oh okay the national flower
Puerto Rico it's my favorite flower as
well and my tattoos I I have a couple of
amanpolas okay and to me that name it's
so different and so poetic it's just
like
I just love my little Amapola so so what
is it like having two kids though like
at the same time because for me I'm
gonna tell you my experience yeah right
I just had a little boy he's three
months
and
having two kids one is cool one is hard
and you know but you got the wife there
and you don't you don't have to
you know it's two on one right but now
we're playing man-to-man defense yeah
and boy when I tell you it is hard it is
hard to do and then you know we're at
the field and so it's hard on the wives
but man like what's your experience like
because for me it is
so my little girl there's a stage where
it's boob it's change the diaper yeah
and hope and fall asleep yeah
um so to me
my time is changing the diaper that's my
time all right diaper my my turn let me
grab her boobs nothing I can do about it
um
it is
it is challenging balancing the time
between the two
because I want the older one to protect
the little one
but also stay confident enough that she
don't need the attention from nobody to
strive in life
so
yeah and this is deep and she's two and
a half but this is where it starts right
you know protect your little sister
she's gonna protect you but at the same
time you don't need mommy and daddy's
attention or her attention to make you
feel good in life was there any jealousy
did the oldest have any any jealousy or
anything
I don't no I haven't sensed that she
wants to hold her it's like a real life
size doll you know she wants to hold her
she wants to play with her
um she's saying I want to dance with
Amapola I'm like baby girl not yet yeah
she can't but she'll be there
um but going back to your hard point
my wife apparently is sleeping great how
I don't she say I sleep more than I
slept with Kalina what I don't know how
she's doing it she's blessed but my
friend my little girl my boy she be
making noises that she she says sleep
she's like ah I'm like
this is what I'm with Carolina I can
sleep for two hours and okay be good
yeah this one is like ah and that keeps
you up she's she's fussing yeah but she
sleeps and she don't cry she's amazing
I'm blessed but it's like I touch her
talk to me like what I if I move you you
make noises if I don't move you you make
I think she's like a loud sleeper
though so whenever she marries someone
good luck sorry about it yeah yeah is
coming in with the noise
I don't know if it's gonna be noisy yes
so you're you're and your oldest
daughter she loves Buck yes she does she
said that right how do you feel about
that how's that is it weird it's good no
no it's good because hey Colleen is very
social she's very social she she can
walk around everybody knows her in the
clubhouse
um she's she finds her way through
um the kitchen gets ice cream oh nice
yeah so
yeah she
yeah my little girl I'm in love man I'm
in love and that's important because
she's gonna feel that yeah that's what
she's going to look for when she gets
older yeah yeah no she she definitely
every time we get in the clubhouse she
always finds her way to try to find oh
yeah of course oh nice that's cool yeah
that's cool yeah so
um yeah Buck is a great guy we all love
Buck
um I mean he's been around so long he's
he's got to be awesome yeah he is he
truly is so in this year you're on Pace
for
at the most power you've hit
um you know me as well and it's weird
because you know coming up we weren't
power guys I didn't bro I played in high
I have one home run yeah you see what
I'm saying and now
you know maybe because we're 30
you know I don't know what it is but
um you know it's weird I having 26
homers right now
it's I don't even know what to think
it's like and then I did the Home Run
Derby which I don't whatever we'll talk
we'll talk about that in a little bit
we got to have a conversation about it
later because you always say I don't hit
home runs and battling practice yeah
which I don't but and again yeah you
want to all right we'll talk about that
but yeah having the 20 like and it's
it's weird man it's really weird and so
for you like what what is it like I hire
you do you feel like you're a different
player not even player but hitter or or
what is it that's you know has what is
the power what what country what is
contributing to the power show I I think
it's it's a byproduct of us Chasing the
Perfection of us of people telling us
he don't hit for power Maybe because I'm
not there I'm conscious yeah I'm not oh
I'm trying to hit home run I'm not doing
that I'm trying to make
solid contact
get a good pitch and don't miss it right
and and
I have learned that my power don't come
from my upper body is my legs and if I'm
grounded
it just it just doesn't yeah it it
happens you know it
do I expect myself to hit 40 home runs
no but I expect myself to
have a good exit velocity
Drive the ball yeah I expect myself to
drive the baseball especially Ben third
too you know I'm saying that's kind of
your it's kind of your job and so really
you're just kind of honing into your job
like you know I'm saying just drive
drive the baseball yeah when I was
leading off my my thought process was
I'm gonna drive the baseball but I'm
gonna get the second okay yeah I'm gonna
get the second I'm gonna do whatever it
takes to get the second now it's I'm
gonna drive the baseball but I'm gonna
get the guy from second home yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know so it it it almost
like you don't change as a hitter
but them entirely changes okay of what
approach you can take to the plate and
so and so
what is the biggest
going from lead off to Third
what is the biggest mentality change
that you had to that you had to go
through in order to for you to be
successful hitting third because it's
definitely a difference that I didn't
have to bring every runner in
like every time there was a guy on base
I I just stressed out oh because I
wanted to so how'd you calm down
understanding that if I'm successful
three out of ten four out of ten with
people on Race I'm the elite of the
elite yes yes you know what I'm saying
so like
yes I wanted the result but the process
of how I went to how how I went I went
through the day and when I was in the
Box yep it nothing mattered but to
stay in the zone and focus on contact
hard contact and and so
no matter where you hit in the lineup
that could be your mindset yeah just get
a good picture hit Square hard contact
and that's it exactly just understanding
that this is who I am
and I give you first second third
whatever fourth whatever base is loaded
in the tenth or nobody on leading off a
game
same thing I am over and over again so
and now I know I do want to kind of
bring up the dirt because I
have you or do you want to do the Derby
I will I will do it you will do it so
I'm gonna tell you my experience on the
Derby for for everyone
do I think I'm gonna win it
you have a chance
you do
for sure do I do you see you you were
there you saw what the guys are putting
down
for the home runs for me buying practice
that's that's a month yes probably two
months yeah I haven't I haven't even
done that so I'm gonna tell you my my
experience for the Derby
I do not know how to hit home runs and
so I I and it sounds great I got you got
26 how many I get it but like the last
time I've hit a home run in BP I cannot
tell you when all I do is hit line
drives over and over again that's what I
try and do and so going in I didn't
practice for it either because I got hot
right before the break and I was like
you know what I'm not trying I'm not
training for this Home Run Derby while I
feel good the plate yeah so I didn't
practice at all until 10 minutes before
the Derby I went in the cage and I just
tried to start hitting homers and so I
went in there yeah I think yeah 11 yeah
11. and so
that's a good round for three years ago
for three years ago yeah not for not for
these animals now so and I go in third
swing in probably my third to Fourth
swing in I knew this ain't it I got no
chance
third swing I got no chance how was your
BP guy he was awesome he was great he
throws me BP every day yeah and so he's
awesome he practice his face coach first
base coach clay yeah he practiced for at
least two weeks so he was locked in and
ready yeah and I think I threw him off
because I didn't hit any home runs and
so he's trying to find where to throw it
and I'm oh in my head so he's not saying
anything he's like okay where do I throw
it because he's not hitting the home
runs in my head I'm like just throw it
I'm not hitting home runs you know what
I'm saying so so for me it was an
awesome experience yeah you have a lot
better chance than I do
um just because our swings are built a
little differently yeah and and but I it
was it was a great experience but unless
my son really really really really
really really wants me to later on in my
career I will never never again never do
it again even I'm just not even if they
changed the format even though they
changed forward because to your point
earlier like what I'm supposed to do
with when Julio goes for 40. yeah you
know what I'm saying like 26 when vladi
put up 26 or 26 or 27 I was like oh my
gosh yeah there's no way I can do it
yeah and so and the basements can be
juice and everything still doesn't
matter they're juice for everybody
they're not just juice for me yeah so
but what do you think watching the Derby
what do you what was the most impressive
performance performance because for me
Julio hitting 40 was very very
impressive by every ball is backspun but
I think when adley hit what 21 away and
then flipped the other side then I think
of them row seven or eight in a row on
the other side in 30 seconds my what
that's what I'm saying they changed the
format we might have a better chance we
might have a better chance because we
get to take our time we hit it pop and
we can sit there and you say oh okay
this is the swing I found it yes then I
can repeat it but when you're going time
like well Randy did you watch Randy my
God he was that was the most impressive
performance for me that was the most
impressive because homeboys
up down swing come back up down swing
come back nothing swing come back no and
he's at home in the front by this box
like he he kept on swinging so quick and
and like consistent I'm like homeboy is
gonna end up in the Grass at some point
he at one point he hit he hit a high it
was a higher Homer yeah I think by the
time one land he had took two more
swings that's what I'm saying and then
Pena VP oh yeah yeah yeah
that's that's that's a huge that's a big
part that's a big because homeboy is
just like yeah right there I don't know
how he got the ball to this
all right so let's go back to Young
Lindor man
so you from Puerto Rico yeah
came to the states mm-hmm
and we know English with no English like
tell me about that tell me about that
how you got here you know what the
reasoning for coming you know I know you
can when you came you're I want to say
your mom didn't come yeah so you came
with pops yeah and so tell me about that
tell me about that transition for you
um it was an exciting
tough
nerve-wracking experience because I was
12 years old with no English and I was
going to a country that I didn't speak
their language
in my mind in my mind
I was going to play baseball
in my mind
in the young Lindor 12 years old mine
but it was more academics than baseball
right
and
I knew things were serious when I'm on
the way to school my dad's trying to
teach me to say I don't understand
and I couldn't comprehend it I legit for
some reason it wouldn't resonate it
wouldn't stay with me I don't understand
I'm like that like my dad got so mad he
wrote it in my hand
oh you going to school and you showed
everybody that
so how in that forced you to learn
English no
force me to learn English because
remember I in my mind I'm coming to play
baseball play baseball and I went
through the ESL program English as a
second language program
the first semester brought our test they
were like
you open you open a book not even a book
it's like a paper it's a paper you fold
it you open it and once I had the story
and this I have five questions multiple
choice ABC oh wow and those were my
tests and like English one and I and I
would I didn't know what the five five
six sentences paragraph oh wow I would
literally
read the question
coming to the ABC whatever word matched
the first sentence that's how you got it
boom I got it wow and that's how I would
do it and did it work at first it worked
okay but I was cheating the system for
sure so that's what they're supposed to
do that yeah that's what I was supposed
to do but that ain't it okay that ain't
it so two kids out there don't cheat the
system just get it done do it the right
way just do it the right way okay
everybody passed in the first semester
everybody went on we took it to a test
to see how our English was if we were
ready to go to the second level or third
level or go to my stream everybody
passed but me okay and that's what
things got real I'm like man this is
embarrassing yeah this is embarrassing
the girls passed my boys passed and I'm
the one left behind by myself in the
classroom so you had to did you had to
redo this was just the same level no you
had to redo the whole class and the next
semester I stayed with just me and the
teacher just one student in the
classroom oh my God you know I like when
you when you think you're cool you you
at first you sit in the back of the
classroom and you you had your moment
you know I know something your teacher
said you're gonna sit in the floor in
the craft classroom so no no it was just
one-on-one it was just y'all just
one-on-one so you was in the back like
yeah I'm Frankie Lindo I'm in the back
of ESL chilling challenge living and now
it's just you and you and with my with
my we might we my classmates they were
Korean Chinese Brazilian Puerto Rican
it's empty just you ten chairs just me
so so um you passed this time right yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
and then you go and you're going through
high school and how how was that whole
experience like going through high
school you're still kind of learning
English at that point yeah uh it was it
was great it was great because at that
point you you're really there to play
yeah I stayed and then I stayed back
um that summer and I took
um ESO three
and then I went to regular classes
English mainstream you were like oh I
made it but I tell you I walked into a
classroom with all the confidence in the
world yeah but I know English I got this
I sit down the first week I'm like I got
enough I can't figure this out hold up
I'll take an extra SEC
um
extra credits and I'm like going after
school
um it was it was fun because it was a
smaller school and we all got along and
and I was playing baseball every single
day in Puerto Rico we practiced twice a
week and we play in the weekends or we
practice one time we played three games
in the week when I came here it was
every day for sure and I loved it and I
live on campus so it was just like I was
working number five in the morning going
to the weight room after school I go
straight to the field it was just like a
college life style in high school and
now you have and now at your school you
have there's a the facility is named
after you yeah how's that how's that
that's cool it's a blessing you know the
school helped me become who I well they
they're a big part of helping me become
who I am today okay they shaped me a lot
and they helped me a lot and I'm a big
believer in education changes people's
life right for the better or for the
worse yep you know
um and not everybody's going to be a big
league player or a professional
basketball player or a soccer player
but with education and you don't have to
have a doctor you don't have to you know
you don't have to go through the whole
system but education can give you that
knowledge that can help you set up
your family yep and and that's why I
always go back that's why I always try
to give back to the education
um
system to the school system because
that's the future right just helping
someone concept their life their life
their family's life yeah generation yep
so and then you got drafted eight
overall we're in the same draft Yeah
Yeah you got drafted eighth overall
and then how was that so like at that
point you know your mom your dad this is
why you came to the U.S yeah right and
so how like when you got drafted what
what did you guys do like you know we
were we were in my agent's house we got
drafted and it was all fun
um but you don't get the money right
nope no we don't no you do not get that
money right away
um so we spent the summer it was my last
summer off yep Our Last Summer out for
sure yeah I haven't had one since yeah I
mean you've got 10 more years too yeah
we got I got nine nine left
um so I don't want summer off I'm good
right we're good
um
then once I got the money
I went yeah what's the first thing you
got I went crazy I bought an iPad
iPod iPad iPad okay you got an iPad I
was in
um a Quality Inn hotel
and they called me and said
congratulations the money hit the brand
kick out and you went crazy I was like
hell yeah and I would look out the
window I saw Best Buy I'm like I'm gonna
go buy something so you went and bought
an iPad bro the picture it was like me
walking in and seeing a picture of an
iPad and I said I want it I think I was
like what I want it what kind that that
one I'm gonna give you whatever's in the
picture you just give it to me and I
swiped the car and walked outside with
no cover no nothing you didn't get any
accessories bro no it was just a matter
of buying something oh you just went
like I did it the the fact that I could
swipe my car and not say decline
that was a big plus that's you know what
it like when you when you know you're
going to buy groceries whatever it is
buy whatever it is and you know your car
is not going to get declined this is the
best feeling in the world it's a big big
feeling now cars do say decline even
when you got money yeah they do when
they do they decline
it's the complete offices
it's the most embarrassing thing it is
it is like sir do you have another one
like
I know exactly what you're saying bro
all right guys so let's keep moving so
what how was your minor league
experience like how
because for me like I've said a couple
of weeks for you
the toughest league for me
um
this may sound bad
but I didn't really experience
I mean for a month which was in in low a
which is Greenville South Carolina this
is before they made all the cuts from
covid right so we had like seven teams
you remember we had like seven teams to
go through before we even made it to the
big leagues yeah and so the first year
the first year was cool I hit 260 but it
wasn't that it was tough it was more the
mechanical flaw yeah and then
I still didn't make that change so I
guess the first year year and month or
so was tough from a mechanical fall once
I fixed that mechanical flaw
it was I I don't know that I hit under
350 until I got to the big leagues
really so yeah I I kind of flew through
the minor league system so my my my
experience was a little different than
most I'm assuming yours is going to be
very similar to mine but I do want to
hear your minor league experience like
what it was like yeah I hit I hit well
into my leagues however
my toughest one was low ah
my shoulders got tired my hips got tired
my legs got and that's probably like the
first year you're a full season you're
full season I was hitting like 320 3 30
and the other side I'm finding myself
hitting 280 I'm like oh my god what
happened without even thinking about you
don't even know what's going on yeah
yeah I remember
um playing the Diamondbacks South Bend
they were in South South Bend IN low way
we were in the Midwest
and
I went over five with five strikeouts
and I've ended the game and
through a curveball and I'm like yes I
got the pitch I wanted
swung through it and I stood there
I hear the catcher saying good job to
the Empire he walks in front of me I'm
still at home plate like I could not
believe I
swung a myth yeah
and they start shaking hands I walked
back to the dog out I've never been the
type of person that slams their stuff
and
I grabbed my bats walk up the stairs
take everything off and go in the shower
and a couple tears came down and I'm
like man this is this is tough yeah this
is tough I was like oh for like 40. oh
okay you were going you were going I was
going through it I was going through it
and
and that's what my dad kind of
understood because my dad has always
been very hard on me and I called my dad
I'm like Dad you're yelling at me
I do not want to strike out I either
it's not like you're going through
trying yeah uh this is tough yeah and
then after that every League became
easier yeah then I was just I would get
bored and play the game within the game
you know it's like all right let me let
me try this you know let me let me do
this but it was low weight low weight
for sure so so you get to the big
leagues right playing we play for a
while with our same teams and then we
get traded yeah and from my my trade my
trade experience was awesome I think
I've said this before it was awesome
um the Red Sox did a great job in
communicating with us on kind of how the
process was going to go weird getting
traded though because I think as we we
all when we get drafted we're saying
like in our head it's like I'm gonna be
a Red Sox forever you're going to be an
Indian forever yeah you know and that's
just not the reality of the game and you
fall in love with the franchise you fall
in love with the franchise
everything about it yeah yeah and and so
when you got traded like what what was
that like for you what what was you know
what was was it weird were you sad you
know what was it it was so
same thing same process they they
educated me they told me what was going
to happen and what wasn't going to
happen and previous years there have
been talks about getting traded but
there is no nothing's gonna happen
nothing's gonna happen and then once
things got out of the series they told
me hey things are going to be a little
more serious it's it's real
um and they gave me a couple teams that
the talks were a little they were warm
yep
um
and then they call me and say Hey you
going somewhere but you're not going by
yourself oh you're going with someone
and we're going to make sure you're
you're good and I appreciated that you
know and and then it was just like a
exciting time like yes this is cool
but no I'm gonna miss everybody I'm not
going I'm not going to Goodyear anymore
but I'm not going to Goodyear
um
and you miss the clubbies you mean you
miss the people you know that an
organization is made by the people right
and and it means everything about it but
then you get here it's like okay you get
used to it and you know you develop it's
not the trade that that is weird it's
really like now you take a different
route to work yeah like you said you
don't know you don't know the guy that's
hoping opening the door you don't know
the people that are parking your car
like you don't know you don't know them
like so he did the pandemic years and
that's when we did it so it was even but
it yeah it was even harder like I it was
good for me though because the Dodgers
have a lot of workers like a lot of
front office a lot of analytics their
analytics team is big and so
I slowly got introduced to everybody I
could only imagine you know if we got
traded during a normal year like getting
to meet so many new people at one time
yeah it probably would get super
overwhelming you
probably May kind of go into a show
yeah like the mass was because I felt
like I didn't know anybody yeah you
don't get to yeah you don't know I was
with them for a year but I still didn't
know like the following year in 22 I see
someone like who are you yeah hey who is
he yeah oh that's so don't get to have
conversations with people oh what you
know and for me like
so I was like that that just brings
another element to conversations you
know like
when you if you only see this you don't
know yeah it's hard yeah you don't want
to talk to anybody like that you know
what I'm saying like that's I get into
that personality as well you know put my
hoodie put my glasses on and I'm looking
down don't talk to me yeah you know
so okay so you've been a short stop your
whole career and you've been the top of
the game
um your whole career
what does it take like being a big
league shortstop obviously you got to be
an athlete
um you got to be able to make plays make
the routine play for sure but what is it
that for you that makes it that keeps
you at the top of your game in in being
a shortstop like being you're constantly
a top five shortstop every year what is
it and this has nothing to do with
hitting this is purely defense what is
it that you do or what is it that you
just kind of got that that keeps you at
the top of the game
my concentration level in defense is
different you're locked in it's just
different it's
for some people they say hitting it's
easy
for me hitting it's not okay for me I I
worked for
what I've done in my career extremely
hard and yeah my my average is not there
but
it's just hidden for me just hasn't I
haven't mastered that one filled in
it's the concentration I have there I
try to match it in hitting and I haven't
I haven't achieved it yet you know it's
for me
you're staying low
you smooth my feet not stopping your
feet just work through the ball step
throw
that I can do in my sleep right yeah so
that's what it sounds like to me it's
like because I feel like I'm very
similar to that when it comes to defense
it to me it's just like kind of effort
like yeah I'm just gonna be be good at
I'm gonna work hard at it and I'm gonna
be fine I'm gonna know how to right how
to you know play defense right I'm gonna
be fine on defense mm-hmm
but when it comes to hitting like I
really had to work
to learn to hit yeah yeah hitting
hitting is is hard yeah it and if you if
you don't
like some people just naturally got it
some people just naturally know how to
swing is there yeah it's like man and
then their thought process is there like
I'm seeing high school kids that their
thought process is like what you got
this right now right yeah like I'm I'm
29 I'm still trying to
accomplish that you know it's but
defense it's just stay low
keep your feet moving watch the bounce
I got you yep now you're mine now step
throw and it just it just works you know
and we're gonna make errors yeah we're
gonna it's gonna happen you know and
there's become
they come when you try to do something a
little
faster and maybe it's the thought
process like I'm gonna I'm gonna throw
the ball like this and you don't have
the ball or I'm gonna step on the base
yeah and you don't have the ball and
then it's like everything's sweet but I
feel like for you though
for you that comes because you got to a
ball that you probably should had no
business getting to anyway and you
realize like oh I can make a play on
this it's gonna be hard to do
and then then that's kind of when that
happens right because every routine ball
I don't I I don't think I've ever seen
a routine like error from you which is
shout out to me for that I appreciate
that it happens it happens I'm sure
there's a couple Clips out there I mean
not but not very often yeah but it's one
of those words it's just
I guess it's the bless is the we've been
I mean that's just what you what what
we've been blessed with that yeah this
is what God bless you yeah excuse me
Frankie yeah I have you struggling I see
you I see it right now you're trying
trying to figure it out uh can we get a
little help on the code for my iPad you
know I uh
yeah I should have uh I should have
known that sorry guys hey it was one of
those where he tapped it and he couldn't
recovered couldn't recovery
looking down looking somewhere else like
man someone I couldn't get it my bad my
bad for throwing you off like that sorry
so so what about who
who would be your top five Short Stop
shortstops in the league right now oh
okay right now right now
um
Turner
okay
um wait we talking hidden or overall I
would say just I would say just overall
just overall overall overall okay
um all right
Turner
Bogarts okay
um um
we can put in their
I think Franco
wander Wonder yep Wonder
um you can put them in there
we can put um Seeger yeah
um
foreign
I got four how would you not put you in
there why would you not put you in there
because I got you in there all day every
day
it's not my job to put myself in there
okay that's fair it's not my job that's
a valid point if do I believe I'm the
best yes but this is it's not my job to
put myself internally yeah okay you know
well I'm putting you in there well I
appreciate that I'm trying to crack up
look I'm trying to crack the top five in
shortstops if I get a couple more games
played You're Gonna Play shortstop
because I seen you a second I think you
have like 19 starts yeah second starts
yeah 15 Stars yeah something like that
um yeah second that's you know I grew I
came up playing second I got
a Dream came true I got to play
shortstop okay and I've been playing it
and
um you know when Mickey Rowe needs a day
then yeah usually I'll go and uh I go
and play short here I think you got it
yeah
but but but you got some tips for me
like you like what
what could what could Frankie Lindor
give to to Mookie Betts you know for
some tips
to anybody but to you especially is play
offense in defense
keep them separate no no play offense in
defense oh played offense on D go get
the ball oh okay don't don't let it go
back up don't they don't as soon as
unless it's a rocket
even there you stay low you know I want
a drop step is not backing up right a
drop
got it so so to me
there's levels right you understand it
way up here I understand it right here
so when you tell me to play offense on
defense I'm scared no I'm not scared no
because I I seen you I saw you I saw you
backhand in the baseball the other day
and you took three four steps you're in
second base and then you win
through the ball that's playing offense
and defense oh there you go it's
attacking the baseball it's not being
fearful of the Hub yeah you make the Hop
don't let the Hop make you even when
it's hit hard like you got to go one
step drop step drop step back in
whatever you know
um it's
I I it's the same thing you do in right
field yeah play together yeah you're
attacking the base where you turn throw
you know we know when you go into your
um left and you come in
is over with yeah do not go to second
base right or don't go to third or third
yeah right because you know you it's
gonna be quick turn throw yeah yeah so
thank you man thank you okay thank you
for the tips
um so have you ever heard of an
Immaculate grid no okay
me neither but we're about to play all
right so what are we playing Immaculate
grid there is a it's a three by three I
see this on Twitter that's the only
place I've ever seen it yeah so it's
never played it yeah yeah I I don't know
anything about it so all right what
we're supposed to do here is
there's a player a player goes in each
screen
a player that played for Baltimore and
Cleveland I have no idea I have no idea
none of these no none of them so but do
you know any of them in Cleveland uh
Cleveland uh a guy that played for
Cleveland immediately my favorite player
Roberto Alamar he didn't he doesn't have
300 oh for for for for he did he played
for Cleveland and Baltimore yeah
Maybe
that's your boy right
with it oh
there you go all right hello eleven
percent that's good is it I think so 11
of the world think like me
yeah yeah there you go hello okay so do
you gotta uh you have someone that that
played with Kansas City in Cleveland
Kansas City and Cleveland I would go
with
Kansas City who only person I only only
only person I know is no I don't know I
don't know any I don't know Kansas City
and Cleveland Kansas City and Cleveland
Kansas City and Cleveland
oh Lord
I don't know none of them what about 300
wins you gotta know that
in Cleveland in Cleveland yeah
there's a 300 Win
I don't know you're supposed to tell me
I told you I don't know none of my Lord
300 wins is a lot that's a lot of wins
can we get an answer please
oh he said no I mean he said hold on
Cy Young well you better be a side young
if you got 300 wins
I don't know look this grid whoever came
up with this grid that's a great idea I
don't know none of them
Baltimore
oh I know someone that managed Mets in
they can put I don't know about manage
no I think
I think it's only players and to me
we're not very good at this game yeah
it's it's Vargas Lefty Vargas remember
Lefty Vargas oh he did play for both
um uh what was his God
he did play for he did it was a Kansas
City and New York he matter of fact he
pitching on he made an All-Star Game
Jason Vargas there you go
Jason Vargas didn't play
you're in the wrong one come on let's
get come on get it right let's go Vargas
Jason Vargas come on here we go yeah
yeah two percent you got that one you're
really good at this I mean it's like
you're really good but you're not I'm
not you get all the low the low
percentages but we don't have none of
that we we don't think like the regular
people alone I ain't thinking from that
perspective yeah okay so let's get out
look we're not it would take us all day
to do this so we don't have all day so
let's get let's get a quick couple of
fan questions couple fan questions so oh
Santana
Carlos Santana yeah you're supposed to
know that I'm not supposed to yeah yeah
Carlo
um fan question one move I saw tiny said
he was most impressed with you at the
All-Star Game this is not really a
question
um can we can we move
um oh what was my reaction to the praise
it was cool you know whatever it is what
it is you know we all know who he is
so much question about you it is it's
whatever bro I mean you know he got to
give defense what they want they don't
want their reaction well I mean it it's
cool
that's the
that's their humble like yeah that's
that's just give the friend I kind of
that's kind of how I feel about it
because you know I mean
no shade to ohtani at all but like
he can say that about everybody you know
what I'm saying about any like yeah you
know he could really say that about us
it feels good to be respectable it does
that part is cool that part is cool but
the the the the the impressed part I
mean shoot you know anybody can impress
anybody and so I just kind of look at it
you're impressing with your homerun
nervy
that was that was bad okay so another
question what type of music what type of
music do you listen to
um
just so off rip like I don't I I don't
you just did listen to me we have
there's a thing called franillo in
Spanish but I mean just for people that
don't roll their art oh my lips are too
big they get in the way
they get in the way I don't I don't I
don't I can do I can do it okay but I
don't do it like the real life
yeah yeah
a little bit but I can roll them I can
roll a little bit you know okay so what
who would you like your a couple a
couple
um well it's obvious about bunny yeah
Daddy Yankee Ozuna
um there's a a girl young Mikko she's
she's she's doing big things
um in the regular World
um
and then I like J Cole okay okay yeah
there we go no I don't know who you're
talking about yeah yeah yeah
I had to I had to I had to take it
towards your this side of the car thank
you thank you and
um
um I like afrobeats I'm huge on
afrobeats on afrobeats so like pre-game
or do you are you a headphone guy yeah
so you put on your headphones and what
do you usually listen to while you
switch it up yeah I switch it up if you
if you if you got if you hit a home or
the day before are you listen to the
same music no I'm not superstitious okay
all right I got too many colors with my
shoes too yeah gloves I got two you got
a lot of Swag yeah how do you keep up
with all that
the way I want to stress that day oh
however you feel it yeah yeah it's like
some days you want to go all black yeah
some days you want to go lighter yes I
do the same thing on the field and
that's that's super dope and it does
show your personality because when you
wore the lime green yesterday and your
glove was matching it yeah right you
know what I'm saying that's that's super
dope and you just
you're just super dope bro and thank you
for coming on this show you know we're
about to rap and this is amazing I'm I'm
glad I actually you know we've talked
and we came up together and and drafted
the same year but we hadn't really got
to sit down and really chop it up like
this and so I'm super glad
um that you came on the show bro
good luck for the with the second half
I'm sure you boys will turn it around
yeah um you got a great group of guys
there and so uh but yeah man uh thank
you guys for coming to watch on base
with mookie bets we got uh Mr smile here
thank you for coming through
um all the dentists be aware he's coming
in and uh he's uh he may put on a little
clinic for you guys so uh but it does it
is gonna cost a pretty penny so damn
right
all right guys I see you guys soon
[Music]
thank you